ein beunruhigender trend langsam aber
stetig steigt die zahl der korona
neuinfektionen in deutschland wieder an
eine richtungsweisende entscheidung das
bundesschiedsgericht der afd bestätigt
den rauswurf von rechtsaußen kallwitz
und das etwas andere bayreuth die
festspiele fallen in diesem jahr aus
partner gibt es trotzdem
[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen bei
den 19 uhr nachrichten für den samstag
sport ist norbert lehmann an meiner
seite
kein wunder von mir ist das schon die
befürchtete zweite welle in deutschland
ist die zahl der korona neuinfektion
nach einiger zeit wieder deutlich
angestiegen und zwar nicht punktuell
sondern flächendeckend politiker sind
alarmiert
schauen wir uns den trend mal an nach
daten der us amerikanischen johns
hopkins universität haben sich im
schnitt der vergangenen woche 510
menschen pro tag angesteckt das ist der
höchste wert seit fast vier wochen
allein gestern zählte das
robert-koch-institut 781 neue fälle und
war immer häufiger erkrankten urlauber
antworten berichtet deutschland ist im
urlaubs modus ziemlich volle strände wie
hier am brombachsee in bayern abstand
halten nicht immer ganz einfach
touristenansturm auch in den bayerischen
alpen auf der suche nach erholung
scheint so mancher zu vergessen dass es
noch da ist das corona virus das die
korona verlust aus dem kopf geht tun
haben bemerkte ich auch wenn ganze
familien ausdrücken da merkt man schon
dass manche leute nicht mehr erschien
für das thema sind und das gilt auch für
die partyszene die klubs sind zu wägen
corona also draußen gefeiert die
vergnügungsmeile im hamburger
schanzenviertel proppenvoll
und das obwohl sich wieder mehr menschen
mit krone infizieren
für die steigenden fälle sind nicht mehr
hotspots wie fleischfabriken
verantwortlich das virus breitet sich
jetzt in ganz deutschland in der fläche
aus zahlreiche landkreise melden
steigende zahlen
die angst wächst vor einer zweiten welle
kritisch wird es wenn es sich eben in
der fläche ausbreitet und auch
infektionsketten im einzelnen nicht mehr
nachvollziehbar sind und letztendlich es
dann zu einer überlastung der
gesundheitssysteme und vor allen dingen
auch der gesundheitsämter kommt momentan
ist die situation auch noch so dass die
gesundheitsämter das im griff haben
das kann sich aber schnell ändern vor
allem wenn sich viele wie hier in
hamburg nicht an die abstandsregeln
halten
das robert koch institut spricht
deswegen von einer sehr beunruhigenden
entwicklung auch weil urlauber das virus
aus dem ausland bei ihrer rückkehr mit
nach deutschland bringen
deswegen wird an deutschen flughäfen
jetzt fleißig getestet noch auf
freiwilliger basis doch der
bundesgesundheitsminister lässt jetzt
prüfen ob eine testpflicht eingeführt
werden kann
infektionsketten nachverfolgen und
unterbrechen
dafür wurde die korona waren app
entwickelt doch nach problemen auf
smartphones mit android systemen wurden
jetzt auch schwierigkeiten bei ios
geräten bekannt das
bundesgesundheitsministerium bestätigte
dass auch bei iphones die hintergrund
aktualisierung nur eingeschränkt laufe
die app funktioniert aber wenn sie
geöffnet werden heißt es in einer
erklärung
weltweit steigen die zahlen rasant an
die weltgesundheitsorganisation spricht
von einem neuen rekord mehr als 280.000
neuinfektionen innerhalb eines tages die
meisten davon in den ohnehin besonders
stark betroffenen ländern
so meldeten die usa und erstmals auch
brasilien jeweils mehr als 67.000
neuinfektionen gefolgt von indien
dort haben sich fast 50.000 menschen neu
angesteckt in den usa wurden die
wirtschaftlichen folgen durch die korona
pandemie bislang durch ein
billionenschweres konjunkturpaket
abgefedert doch das läuft heute aus
auf neue hilfen konnten sich
republikaner und demokraten bislang
nicht einigen millionen betroffene
bekommen kein geld mehr und gleichzeitig
endet der kündigungsschutz für säumige
mieter aus washington heike slansky eine
geduldsprobe für millionen amerikaner
massenarbeitslosigkeit mit knapp
bemessener hilfe des staates ohne
besserung in sicht jetzt läuft auch noch
das hilfspaket für pandemie betroffene
aus washington aus
es ist total frustrierend die pandemie
ist doch nicht ihre schuld sie brauchen
alle unterstützung lautstark ziehen sie
durch die straßen hier in new orleans
und auf ihr elend aufmerksam zu machen
ab diesem wochenende kommt für mehr als
25 millionen betroffene kein scheck mehr
aus washington 600 dollar die woche
gestrichen
600 dollar ist eine menge geld für mich
erst recht solange ich in meiner branche
nicht mehr arbeiten kann
im kongress streiten sich republikaner
und demokraten um die verlängerung der
unterstützung konnten sich bislang aber
nicht einigen der grundschule müssen
aufpassen dass manche mit der hilfe
nicht mehr geld zur verfügung haben als
wenn sie arbeiten würden darum geht die
republikaner haben den bezug zur
realität verloren sind untereinander
völlig zerstritten während die menschen
im land weiter leiden weniger
hilfsleistungen unbezahlte rechnungen
millionen betroffenen droht jetzt auch
noch die zwangsräumung
wir haben schon 12.000 dollar
mietschulden und müssen das geld
irgendwie unserem vermieter zurückzahlen
kein corona hilfspakete in sicht für
knapp 30 millionen arbeitslose dazu
steigende infektionszahlen und ein
politischer streit ausgetragen auf dem
rücken der ärmsten allesamt zur
entwicklung der korona pandemie
aufbereitet in interaktiven karten und
grafiken finden sie jederzeit in unserer
zdf heute darf andreas kalbitz noch in
der afg bleiben oder nicht dass
beschäftigte die partei seit wochen
heute entschied das schiedsgericht der
afd der parteiausschluss ist rechtens
andreas kalbitz ist neben dem thüringer
landeschef egger eine zentrale figur des
aufgelösten völkisch nationalistischen
flügels betrieben wurde der rauswurf von
parteichef leuten die heutige
entscheidung könnte die zutiefst
zerstrittene partei weiter spalten david
gebhard berichtet half die gegen auf die
beuten gegen kallwitz
wieder beschäftigt sich die partei mit
sich selbst und braun linie nach
rechtsaußen der brandenburger andreas
kalbitz vor dem parteischiedsgericht das
heute mit großer mehrheit entscheidet
dass der rauswurf des extrem rechten
rechtens war
ein rauswurf den jörg merten
vorangetrieben hatte unsere position ist
ja die dass es eine eine verfestigt
rechtsextremen vorbeter gibt und wenn er
sich davon nicht hinlänglich distanziert
glaube ich ist das nur sehr klare
aussage im mai hatte der afg
bundesvorstand keilwitz mehrheitlich aus
der partei geworfen auch weil diese eine
mitgliedschaft bei der inzwischen
verbotenen rechtsextremen heimattreuen
deutschen jugend verschwiegen habe ein
verein der laut bundesverwaltungsgericht
die waffen ss als vorbildhafte
organisation ansah eine offizielle
mitgliedschaft bestreitet kein witz bis
heute diese besuche habe ich nie
bestritten auf den umstand dass man sich
da mal verirrt hat das ist völlig
richtig was sagt das über mich aus sagt
nämlich aus dass ich politisch auch für
mich eine entwicklung vollzogen habe und
weg gefunden habe der ganz klar fest auf
der freiheitlich demokratischen
grundordnung basiert kalbitz will seinen
rauswurf vor dem parteigericht nicht
hinnehmen und sich über zivile gerichte
wieder zurück in die afg klagen
bis zuletzt hatte er rückendeckung aus
teilen der parteiführung von timo grub
aller alice weidl und alexander gauland
ich erwarte von den dreien dass sie das
urteil des bundesgerichtes das ja das
höchste gremium in der partei ist
akzeptieren ja dass sie vor allen dingen
auch jetzt keine besondere touren mehr
machen und dass sie einfach sich auf
ihre arbeit für die sie gewählt worden
sind konzentrieren
kalbitz anhänger in der fdp wollen die
niederlage nicht hinnehmen
demonstrationen heute vor dem gebäude im
netz wird das verfahren als schauprozess
abgewertet und gegen parteifreunde
gehetzt der innerparteiliche hass geht
weiter nach russland wo die regierung
recht angespannt in den fernen osten des
landes bieten dürfte seit zwei wochen
gehen dort zehntausende auf die straße
aus protest gegen den kreml acht
flugstunden von moskau entfernt liegt
die provinz la barofsky deren gouverneur
vorgang
sitzt jetzt in untersuchungshaft der
vorwurf mehrfacher auftragsmord für
seine anhänger ist klar
präsident putin will ihn loswerden
christian sehen das ganze land soll auf
die straße gehen rufen die demonstranten
in traboch slot behörden sind es diesmal
rund 6500 oppositionelle zählen bis zu
100.000 die menschen in russlands fernem
osten sind sauer sie fordern ein
öffentliches gerichtsverfahren führen
festgenommenen gouverneur der nach
moskau gebracht wurde
sie fühlen sich bevormundet wir haben
den gouverneur gewählt und wir wollen
gehört werden und selbst entscheiden was
mit ihnen geschieht bringt ihn hierher
und ein fairer und offener prozess wird
entscheiden ob er verurteilt wird oder
nicht
auslöser der proteste vor zwei wochen
die festnahme des beliebten gründer
sergej vorgang der vorwurf vor 15 jahren
soll er mehrere morde an unternehmen in
auftrag gegeben haben der 50 jährige
gehört der rechtspopulistischen und
system namen partei ldpr an die
gouverneurswahl hatte vor gaal vor zwei
jahren überraschend gewonnen gegen den
kandidaten der kreml-partei er hat sehr
viel für die region gemacht aber unsere
macht hat ihn einfach gefressen er hat
für kinder kostenlos essen organisiert
für ihn waren alle gleich
putin tritt zurück rufen sie inhaber
rast der protest richtet sich auch gegen
das system putin
es ist möglich dass die unzufriedenheit
mit dem putin regime entfernen aus
zunimmt und man kann im prinzip davon
ausgehen dass die proteste auch in
anderen regionen stärker werden
wladimir putin hat bereits einen neuen
gouverneur eingesetzt beschwichtigt hat
dass die menschen nicht schon vor seiner
reise nach chabarowsk gaben ihm die
demonstranten mit auf den weg
er brauche da keine winter sachen
einpacken so lange werde er gar nicht
bleiben
sie wurden jahrzehntelangen schikaniert
degradiert oder entlassen
homosexuelle soldaten in der bundeswehr
bis ins jahr 2000 gab es sogar einen
entsprechenden erlass der ihre
diskriminierung fest schrieb
verteidigungsministerin kramp
karrenbauer plant jetzt betroffene
finanziell zu entschädigen
ein entsprechendes gesetz soll auch für
ehemalige soldaten der nationalen
volksarmee der ddr gelten mehr
anerkennung und gleichstellung für
lesben schwule trans inter und
bisexuelle dafür demonstrieren jedes
jahr hunderttausende menschen am
christopher street day in berlin sei das
bislang so aus rund eine million
unterstützer ging allein im vergangenen
jahr auf die straße solche
menschenmassen sind jetzt aber undenkbar
für den csd in der hauptstadt war also
kreativität gefragt wie es schneider
so ganz will die homosexuelle szene in
berlin dann doch nicht auf eine parade
verzichten
die lesbische gemeinde hat einen marsch
organisiert sichtbarkeit ist das motto
mehrere tausend menschen ziehen durch
die mitte berlins
unser anliegen ist einfach nur zu zeigen
dass es letzten gibt das wir
unterrepräsentiert
dass wir vielfältig bunt und cool sind
also wir leben mitten in berlin ich kann
mich jeden tag frei bewegen das ist kein
problem
ich oute mich überall wo ich bin
trotzdem passiert diskriminierungen
alltäglich und genau das müssen wir
angehen
ansonsten ist dieses jahr alles anders
der großteil des csd findet digital
stadt gesteuert von dieser bühne als
online-stream vereine und künstler haben
video botschaften geschickt es gibt
diskussionsrunden
die organisatoren wollten nicht alles
absagen wegen corona denn eine
grundlegende akzeptanz von schwulen
lesben und transgender ist noch lange
nicht erreicht
gewalt gegen schwule und drag queens und
lesbische frauen in berlin dem zu
dafür wollen wir einstehen dass das
endlich aufhört dass wir sichtbar sind
und dass wir normaler teil einer
normalen gesellschaft endlich sein
können der berliner csd blickt auch
immer in die welt hinaus unterstützung
für diskriminierte schwule und lesben
europa ist ein großes thema die eu wurde
aufgefordert zu handeln
die sichtbarkeit der queeren gemeinde
war heute da die große party danach muss
in diesem jahr aber ausfallen
sommerzeit ist eigentlich festspielzeit
auch in bayreuth und dass sie es bislang
immer alles was rang und namen hat
trifft sich auf dem grünen hügel
doch die wagner-festspiele erleben
turbulente zeiten festspielchefin
katharina wagner ist erkrankt und die
korona pandemie macht den berühmten
opernfestivals einen strich durch die
rechnung
von einem ungewöhnlichen premierentag in
bayreuth christiane hastrich und barbara
lueg die auftrag fanfare lassen sie sich
nicht mehr
picknick auf der grünen wiese statt
richard wagner im festspielhaus ein
sommer ganz ohne bayreuth geht eben
nicht
der kern ist die oper aber es ist eben
auch viel mehr noch drum rum und
wenigstens das drum herum machen wir
dieses jahr trotzdem genommen
eigentlich sollte der ring des
nibelungen hier premiere feiern jetzt
alternativprogramm public viewing im
park der villa wahnfried heute
nachmittag in kleiner besetzung
dirigiert von christian thielemann aus
dem ehemaligen wohnzimmer des
komponisten
[Musik]
immerhin ein trostpflaster in der
situation geht erstmal darum überhaupt
zu zeigen dass wir da sind denn ich
meine
bis vor kurzem hatten wir eine neue
option werde mal gesagt es gibt gar
nichts
nun also ganz andere töne aus dem
letzten haus
[Musik]
digitale angebote videokunst
ungewöhnliche perspektiven online
abrufbar für jeder machen
[Musik]
ein neuer weg vorbei und dieser neue
blick auf die festspiele ist dringend
notwendig denn in den letzten jahren war
man hier mehr mit familiären schlachten
um die festspielleitung beschäftigt als
mit innovation und frischen ideen
insofern könnte corona und die absage
eine echte chance für die bayreuther
festspiele sein und so will man jetzt
über zusätzliche konzepte nachdenken die
hier in der nächsten saison zur
aufführung kommen könnten
ja und nun zu die norbert und zum
fußball in frankreich ja unter hat
meister paris st germain das double
geschafft mit einem verdienten 1 0 sieg
über as saint-etienne ein pokalfinale
vor der krone bedingten kulisse von nur
5000 zuschauern bei dem es hart zur
sache ging
betroffen vor allem paris superstar
klärung im rp thomas tuchel verliert vor
verärgerung beinahe seinen mund nasen
schutz der deutsche trainer der pariser
millionen mannschaft sieht eine der
wichtigsten spieler am boden
kilian papi rüde gebremst von suntech
ihn spieler per das foul folgerichtig
mit rot bestraft ps 60 minuten lang in
überzahl
zu diesem zeitpunkt hat papi durch seine
schnelligkeit bereits das 1 0 für den
favoriten vorbereitet
und nachschuss die vierzehnte minute
meister paris bringt den 13 pokalsieg
minimalistisch nach hause aber papiss
verletzung könnte das große ziel
gefährden den gewinn der champions
league im august er kommt an krücken und
mit sprunggelenks schiene zur
siegerehrung erster diagnose eine starke
verstauchung nichts gebrochen da darf
dann schon ein bisschen mit gefeiert
werden
saisonstart der chinesischen super
league nach einem halben jahr verspätung
unter strengster hygiene und
sicherheitsauflagen und ohne publikum
wegen corona in der partie wo hingegen
ging da hoch wird beim einlauf der
mannschaften durch aufgezeichnete
fangesänge für etwas stimmung gesorgt
danach eine schweigeminute stilles
gedenken an die opfer der pandemie die
chinesische liga hätte am 22 februar
beginnen sollen nun an turnieren nur
zwei spielorten in zwei achtergruppen
johann gewinnt übrigens am ende sein
erstes spiel mitzunehmen
ja und mehr zur saison eröffnung der
chinesischen super league
am sonntagnachmittag bei uns in der zdf
sportreportage um 17 uhr 10
auch der golfsport hat unter corona
gelitten jetzt endlich wieder ein
hochkarätig besetztes amateurturnier
hierzulande beim golfclub stolper heide
in berlin europas nummer zwei die
französin lucie marschieren siegte bei
den frauen beste deutsche alexander
försterling als dritte und die
glückwünsche hinterher wurden in
perfekter pandemie etikette per fuß
ausgetauscht sehr elegant per fuß oder
per ellbogen wofür soll man sich
entscheiden
wie machen es für namens der fuß auf dem
gehweg köln später per elfer in brüssel
hat man den ellbogen benutzte zum
sonntagmorgen ändert sich das wetter
kräftiger regen zieht auf und dazu gibt
es gewitter
die einzelheiten erfahren sie gleich von
essent harry das war es von uns danke
für ihre aufmerksamkeit
etwas später um drei viertel elf begrüßt
sie claus kleber im heute journal
wir wünschen ihnen ein schönes
wochenende und freuen uns wenn sie
morgen wieder mit dabei sind
[Musik]
einen schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter nun erreicht uns
doch regen und das sogar in kräftiger
form von westen her
mit diesem tief hier über dem
vereinigten königreich das regengebiet
durchsatz mit gewittern schwenkte
relativ rasch morgen im tagesverlauf
nach osten schauen die details an in der
nacht sind die schauer und gewitter
schon bis etwa zur mitte voran gekommen
teilweise gibt es auch heftigen winter
so stürmisch kann es sein
im osten ist es trocken und auch im
süden und das bei temperaturen von 19
grad im südwesten und zwölf grad die
richtung bayerischer wald dort ist es am
kühlsten morgen am vormittag sind die
schauer und gewitter schon deutlich
weiter nach osten gezogen
dabei kann es kräftig schauern unter
größeren mengen geben in kurzer zeit
ganz im westen lockert es schon wieder
auf und die sonne zeigt sich und zum
nachmittag waren dann die schauer und
gewitter
deutlich weiter nach osten in den süden
und auch ganz im norden da gibt es
schauer
temperaturmäßig liegen wir bei 27 grad
im südwesten und 19 grad in
schleswig-holstein die nächsten tage
verlaufen hauptsächlich ruhig einige
schauer sind dabei temperaturen montag
bis 33 grad und dienstag ist es am
heißesten mit bis zu 35 grad
ein schöner abend